the the presentation I'm going to give
you is a presentation I give to to law
faculties it was my job talk paper
um it is uh to law students and and and
people uh who think about these in
illegal terms and a theme of the
presentation is that the way that
lawyers think about these things aren't
accurate um or or are somewhat
misleading and so a lot of what I'm
going to say to you it's where I'm not
just like repurposing a talk uh and and
just um that will not at all be
interesting or relevant to you but a lot
of what I'm saying is like here's how
the systems actually work that will be
like bread and butter to you that'll be
like well duh um but maybe you'll be
interested in understanding why how
lawyers think about it and why the
language and think the Frameworks that
that we come from when we approach these
issues and why there is some disconnect
uh between those two uh to uh frames of
reference and why this could be a
problem and why we need to find a way to
to walk across campus so to speak okay
so
um the the paper the presentation is
content moderation is systems thinking
um I'm just going to Chuck up a sort of
definition for how I'm thinking about
content moderation for the rest of this
talk
um which is their system platform
systems and rules that determine how
they treat user generated content on
their services now we could have long
debates about this definition I'm sure
um yes it is about how platforms uh uh
design their systems and it's also
pretty Broad and that's going to be
important for the theme of my talk
because this is a lot broader than how a
lot of lawyers Regulators uh and
um and policy makers think about uh uh
content moderation
um
and the the argument that I make in this
paper is that there's been this sort of
first wave of content moderation
institutional design both in platforms
and in policy and that we need to think
about uh replacing that with it with a
second wave okay but before we get to
that argument let's talk about what the
first wave was
um okay so the first wave relies on this
standard picture of content moderation
uh within platforms and the way that
people think about content moderation in
this framework is that there's sort of
an executive uh at the platform
and they sit Above the Rest of the
company uh one of which uh one part of
which is the content moderation policy
team the people that sit there and think
really hard about speech rules and think
oh this is where we want to draw the
line on hate speech and that policy team
is completely separate from the rest of
the company
including uh you know uh product growth
Engineers government relations teams the
people who work on ads uh there's just
this nice little sort of group of speech
philosophers sitting off in the corner
thinking about how do we get these
things right and then they sit above
this massive bureaucracy um in the in
the platform uh that has a a whole
system of Frontline content moderators
that are dispersed around the globe and
that assisted by artificial intelligence
tools that make the first content
moderation decision and if you're not
happy with the decision that you get
there you can appeal it up certain
number of tiers and so this is how
content moderation is thought of in in
this imagination and
when I give this talk to lawyers I say
this should look really familiar to you
um this kind of picture because this
picture of how content moderation work
works is a pretty good analog for how we
think about uh
offline speech adjudication and when I
talk about it in America I mean First
Amendment uh adjudication but other
legal systems around the world right you
have a decision made against you and if
you're not happy you can go to court and
if you're not happy with what the court
says you can peel it up and then
ultimately you might end up at the
Supreme Court of the United States or
whatever uh and the the the reason why
this picture has been so uh dominant and
persuasive has been because a lot of
these systems and a lot of the writing
that has been done about this in the in
the literature that policy makers and
and uh and and things are reading and
also the way that these um systems have
been constructed within platforms uh has
been by lawyers uh and when lawyers see
speech they think of these kind of
judicial-esque hierarchies for thinking
about these things
um and so
when we're thinking about how to reform
and how to make content moderation quote
unquote better
um the key mode of error correction and
accountability if you think about
content moderation in that form is very
individualistic like what happened in
this individual case to an individual
piece of content uh and it's exposed
what happened uh to an individual piece
of content and how do we fix the
treatment of that individual uh that
individual decision after the fact
um
and for lawyers uh when you're thinking
in those terms you think about process
being really good we lawyers love
process so if the the problem with this
system is we need more due process for
users we need to give them more
reasoning we need to give them more say
in the decision and the more process the
better the more sort of like opportunity
to appeal
um and uh and things like that um the
better this system is going to work
now
the problem with this and again this may
just be sort of like totally uh old yawn
news to you but when I present this to
to people that are thinking about this
in in policy making terms this is kind
of mind-blowing for them
um is that during the time that I'm
speaking today
um Facebook's going to take down over
700 pieces of con the 700 000 pieces of
content not at 700 even that though
would be kind of difficult for uh
lawyers to to deal with
um YouTube's going to take down nearly
200 a quarter of a million pieces of
content Tick Tock 35 000 videos uh and
this Facebook oversight board thing
which we're going to come back to later
that sort of what operates as this
Supreme Court style thing is going to
receive 107 petitions to review uh
meta's decisions
um that doesn't include a whole bunch of
other kinds of decisions that's only
take Downs right that doesn't involve
decisions where someone's flagged a
piece of content and meta or what or
YouTube decides to leave it up and all
the other kinds of content moderation
decisions that we might think of such as
flagging sorry such as labeling or
downranking or fact checking or anything
like that so this is only a small subset
in its entire history the entire history
of the Supreme Court is decided around
246 First Amendment cases
um so that's a pretty different way of
thinking uh and it the the the the point
is that it's a it's a different kind of
problem uh when you have that kind of
scale
um you can't use sort of uh old old
systems for thinking about these
problems so we need to think about
content moderation not as just
not just as like a bigger version of the
problem that we have the scale shift is
so different that we need to think about
it completely differently we need to
think about it more as a system which
means instead of thinking about it in
these rights-based terms like here is my
speech and here's the rule and here is
my claim
um we need to think of it much more as a
sort of regulatory system and and system
design
um
so
the the the reason why this argument is
important um is because this this sort
of judicial-esque model has really been
quite dominant in the way that a lot of
lawyers and legal academics have been
talking about it
um that we talk about content moderators
at the inner capacity very similar to
judges
um we talk about the need uh for a kind
of uh digital constitutionalism for
thinking about this in much more sort of
rights-based speech beats uh Speech
rights terms in Civil Society the the
policy prescriptions that come up a lot
of the time are about
um adding more human review to
individual decisions provide having
users provide more information
um having more reasoning
um having more appeals uh that that can
more effectively review individual cases
um and this had then flown through to a
lot of Regulation so
this is a bill from uh this is Bill in
Congress uh the The Pact Act is one
example that has uh similar kind of
prescriptions the packed act would
require platforms to notify every time a
notify a user every time a decision is
taken against them give them an
opportunity to appeal and give them
reasoning
um similarly there's bills in Texas and
Florida that have done the same thing
now those cases we're going to come back
to those at the end to flag them for you
they're gonna they are going to head up
to the Supreme Court in the next year
most likely
um we can talk more about that if that's
of interest but these bills in Texas and
Florida they're currently on ice so the
platforms don't have to comply with them
yet but uh potentially could they have
all of these uh same prescriptions in
them the the obligation of the platform
uh in if they have to comply with these
laws is that every time they remove a
piece of content they have to notify
provide an appeal provide a a reason for
the determination every single time and
that's because this this picture of
content moderation is what they're
thinking about when they're thinking
about how to reform moment and similarly
in the European Union and this is coming
down that this is uh passed and going to
come into Force this is not a
hypothetical
um the European Union uh will require
big platforms to provide a statement of
reasons every time that they
um take a Content moderation decision
have an internal complaint handling
system uh that uh that is open for at
least six months after a decision is
made
um that that a user can can use to
contest a decision six months
um like
if a decision is made about your you
know uh if the if the platform thinks
that your picture of an onion is boobs
uh and you have to you have to have a
right to to appeal that decision five
months later like it it seems this is a
really you know quite burdensome uh
procedural requirement on on platforms
that might not necessarily uh result in
um significant benefits
um and then on top of that the platform
also has to uh provide for you to be
able to appeal your decision uh to an
outside third party independent
third-party Arbiter so really extensive
um really like what I want to underline
to you is this is like really right the
idea here is that every individual piece
of speech is is so important that we
need to think about it in these really
individualistic uh terms now I think
that this picture thinking about content
moderation in this way
um is blind to
all of the different ways that content
moderation decisions get made that are
outside of that bureaucracy
um within a platform and uh the ex-anti
systemic design choices and trade-offs
that affect uh Speech how speech moves
through the platforms I.E it's blind to
a lot of the thinking that all of you in
this room spend a lot of time doing
about how do we design this system uh to
be to be healthier
um in the in the first place rather than
fix up the mistakes at the end
um and so you know in terms of
heterogeneity of Institutions involved
in content moderation this part of
content moderation is just a very small
part of how platforms think about
designing their systems uh to to make
their environments uh enforce their
their rules and make their environments
healthier as you all know so even within
a single platform uh you have behavioral
content moderation that falls outside
that picture so you have like groups
looking for influence operations that
are not focused on individual pieces of
content but are focused on how a group
behaves as a whole so you're not going
to see those kinds of patterns if you're
only looking in individual pieces you
have government relations teams that
have their own perspectives on how
speech decisions should get made and you
have product design teams the people
that are deciding uh where to put the
like button and the um and the share
tools and all of the interventions that
might affect how speech moves through a
platform that aren't those individual
decisions about a piece of content and
then you also have people outside the
platform making decisions too so
we're increasingly seeing
content moderation decisions delegated
to outside third parties so for example
fact-checking organizations or
authoritative institutions you know some
of the most prominent being for example
the World Health Organization policy was
imported into platforms content
moderation decisions uh during the
pandemic
um
we also have uh users increasingly
involved and empowered in content
moderation decisions uh who don't their
decisions aren't really seen in the
bureaucracy and and so much of the
regulation that we see coming down the
pipe for thinking about how to regulate
content moderations and platforms a
blind to community-based moderation the
the mismatch between those two uh is is
is really um is is really obvious
um we also have governments who interact
with platforms and and uh in in
different ways both formally and
informally to affect content moderation
and increasingly we have um
uh other platforms so we're increasingly
seeing much more collaboration across
the industry uh both big and small in
terms of Technology sharing database
sharing
um uh information sharing that um that
means that
you know if you are looking Downstream
at the end decision and you're only
thinking about that decision you're
going to miss where exactly uh the the
actor necessarily that was actually
responsible for that decision in the
first place so the main point here from
this like very busy uh uh you know very
amateurally drawn slide um is that if
you're thinking only about that point
you're missing a whole lot of the system
um
and I'm not going to spend too long on
this because you all know this far
better than I but if you're thinking
only about that bureaucracy and those
kinds of individual Rule and the
individual piece of content you're
missing all of the systemic design
choices that are involved
um in in uh in uh doing content
moderation so one of the big ones is
when you're operating at that scale
um you have to acknowledge excuse me in
a way that the legal system doesn't that
you are going to get things wrong you
are going to make mistakes you are just
not going to make 700 000 decisions
correctly every hour and so you have to
you know whether it's the um the the
confidence threshold on the the tools
that you use
um or or whatever it is whether you
change the way that you think about
writing your rules so that's blunter or
maybe over broad because you want to
apply a simple rule in a large amount of
cases you have to make these choices
about false positives and false
negatives in a way that we don't really
think about in like a First Amendment
context or an international human rights
law context about we're thinking really
particularly about those individual
facts where a court will like to look at
an individual speech act for eight
months and then come out to an outcome
um it's it's not really that same uh
problem of um of error tolerance
um we've already talked about how
platforms have to think about you know
how much of the rules are they going to
enforce and how much of it are they
going to leave for their users to
enforce uh and and moderate themselves
in a way that is a system design choice
that isn't uh that isn't visible if
you're only looking at that bureaucracy
um
super curious for some of your thoughts
about this I have been deeply skeptical
in my work about the overall benefits of
always providing users for like
procedural Justice in such extensive
ways in every case because
if you are you know loading on lots and
lots of uh
procedure and due process
there are costs to that there are costs
to
um efficiency getting things done
quickly which can be really important
there are costs to
um and we can talk about more more about
this in in a minute but there's there's
not necessarily evidence or there isn't
always evidence that decisions are
more correct the more times that they're
reviewed uh it might just be um that the
the people that complained the loudest
and the longest um get their their
content reviewed more often
um and so there's these real trade-offs
as well that get made in thinking about
how to design a system uh that I that
I'm I'm not confident that this like
piling on all these extra procedures is
necessarily
um uh going to to Target the exact
problems that we have
um and this is sort of tied into this
idea of consistent versus contextual
decision making so you also have to
think if you're a meta and you are
operating in Brazil and the US and
Myanmar and Germany
um you have a choice to make about do
you have a rule that you apply
consistently
um that you know a user can have post
the same piece of content and will get
the same result in each context
regardless of like social context and
that will feel in a sense just but it
also could feel extremely unjust because
you might have different social norms
and different uh political environment
different completely different
um context and so
how do how does how does Justice play
into those kinds of choices when you're
operating at the scale um that these
platforms operate and I am as you know I
should have said at the beginning but as
parent now really thinking about the big
platforms um that that many of the uh
regulations are targeted at
okay
um the reason why
this appeal system this individual
exposed review system isn't um uh
necessarily going to be effective at
identifying problems with content
moderation is that individual errors are
going to be poor vehicles for
identifying systemic failures so you
they may be a canary in the coal mine
but it's not enough to just find an
individual error it might be that that
error is a reasonable rational rational
result of an error Choice made further
Upstream on the other hand it could be
evidence of systemic bias within the
platform
um that that is that is carried carried
out and if you're just reviewing that
individual decision you're not going to
see those systemic issues nor are you
going to fix them
um because if you just sort of fix uh
that one time that uh that as we know
for example
um uh black users suffer
disproportionate harm under like hate
speech uh algorithms that or you know
there's been research showing hate
speech algorithms that many of these
major platforms use if you just fix them
one by one you are not going to be
fixing the Upstream problem of system
design that's that's fixed that's
causing that problem
um
it's resulting in the this picture of
content moderation is also resulting in
mandates that are going to be
transparency theater where it's
requiring platforms to reduce a whole
bunch of reports about how many
aggregate decisions did you make in this
particular uh uh period
um that is what platforms already do and
actually reveal very little about what's
going on on the platform they're great
for producing slides for slideshows that
tell you how many pieces of content a
platform will take down in an hour but I
don't know how much you say are
necessarily for doing anything deeper
than that and we've already talked about
uh the the process theater that some of
these mandates
um Can can result in
um where uh
users get more process but don't
necessarily
result in Greater Justice across the
platform overall um I'm just going to
sort of go through this really quickly
the transparency theater is you know
what I was saying that because it's
focusing on these uh decisions in the
bureaucracy a lot of the transparency
mandates that lawmakers in in Congress
in the states in in the EU are requiring
is like figures about you know how many
pieces of content did you take down in
this three-month period and Facebook is
really in favor of this regulation it's
like yes regulate us and yes make us do
comply with that because it already uh
produces those kinds of reports um and
it would not be very costly and it would
be much more costly for other platforms
to have to comply with this uh this kind
of um
this kind of Regulation uh
um
you know these these reports are
relatively uninformative they don't tell
you the accuracy of the figures that
that are presented they don't tell you
if a platform is taking down you know 50
more of that kind of content in a period
is that because they change their
algorithm is it because users posted
more hate speech is it you know what
what is the what is the reason for that
increase and that that is not a clear
from the
um uh the the face of the report and
also might lead to content moderation
inflation where like there is an
incentive at the moment I think for
platforms to say we are taking down ever
more pieces of content uh look how good
a job we're doing we caught one billion
spam accounts um and that might have
perverse incentives on how uh platforms
think about content moderation
um okay uh
process Theta talked about this briefly
um
about the the costs of uh of of uh doing
all of that extra process
I do want to be clear that I don't think
it's not it's not the fact that I think
the all process should be should be
gotten rid of I think it just needs to
be thought about much more carefully
about what is the goal that you're
trying to achieve with uh extra process
and are you actually going to be
achieving that outcome which is not what
these regulations are um
are targeted at so it may be very well
the case that like in hate speech for
example the kinds of errors that are
made
um are the kinds that will be uh uh
much more
um easily identified or better
identified and fixed through a
uh or um an extensive appeals process
through reasoning through explaining why
I said something uh and and getting
reasoning back that might not
necessarily be true for adult nudity uh
for example where the appeals process
might be much less useful
um in terms of uh individuals that use
appeals are not necessarily
representative
um so this is uh information from The
Meta oversight boards transparency
report
um and
so it can hear appeals from users who
are unsatisfied with their uh with their
decision taken on on on any of matters
platform or on Facebook or Instagram and
those top lines the pink line
um is the number of times users appealed
if they had their content taken down and
they wanted it to be put back up and
that bottom line you can't you almost
can't see it because it's so close to
the zero line is the number of times
people appealed
um when they saw a piece of content that
they thought broke the rules and they
thought it should be taken down now
there's a huge gap and there's no reason
that that we necessarily know of to
think that meta is much much better at
identifying uh takedowns than it that
it's uh
taking down content
you know what I mean there's no reason
to think
um that meta is getting one decision
right much more often than it is getting
the other decision right why might we
see that disparity well because the user
whose content is taking down is like
much more invested and they have to like
appeal three times and they're like okay
I got the wrong decision I'm going to
appeal it they've got the wrong decision
I'm going to appeal again and then
they've got their own and they're just
going to keep appealing because they
really want their post back on the
platform someone who sees someone else's
post they think well that breaks the
rules then they kind of have to go
through the process again and maybe
provide more reasoning at some point
they're probably going to go ah I don't
care that much and so using an appeal
system isn't necessarily going to fix uh
isn't necessarily going to be a
representative way of fixing um systemic
problems either
okay
um
so the the argument that I make in the
paper is that we need to stop thinking
about this so much from an exposed
fixing things behind after the fact so
thinking much more about system design
choices uh which uh I hope many of you
in this room are in favor of and instead
of thinking in individualistic terms
thinking about it much more in terms of
systems and going from rights-based
thinking to much more regulatory
thinking
um which is brings us to that argument
that I was making on the first slide
about moving from this first wave of
thinking about regulation to moving to a
second wave
um
that looks much more in two different
buckets of reforms than the kind of
imposing all of these uh procedural
appeals mechanisms um which may not be
applicable for every kind of platform
um thinking much more about uh
structural measures and more systemic
procedural measures uh rather than
individualistic so
structurally uh I'm interested in
thinking about separation of functions
um what I mean by well I'll come back to
what I mean by that complaints
mechanisms
um disclosures of third-party decision
making and retention of and provision
for access to data so separation of
functions what I mean by this
um is in part uh I mean one of the
biggest concerns that we have in
platform content moderation decision
making and system design is that it it
is not that they're biases in the way
that the system is designed or the
decision makers and we have for example
evidence to believe that people who are
involved in like government relations
um come in and step in after the fact
into content moderation decisions and
change them even though uh the the
decision was taken according to the
platforms rule so
um I think separation of functions
eliminates the incentives uh that makes
biased conduct possible by hiving off
those people from the possibility of
interviewing in decisions
um and so to the extent that decisions
are made there should be no capacity for
people outside
um that structure to interfere with it
um
I think a complaints mechanism for for
whistleblowing uh
um
would be useful for identifying systemic
failures that aren't going to be
available aren't going to be apparent
from the uh aggregate from looking at
individual cases
um to the extent that outside contacts
are involved in decision making
um I think that and this is in
particular as a free speech scholar
thinking about how governments influence
decisions
um I think is one of the things that I
would really like to see is much more
transparency about the way in which
platforms interact with governments but
also with each other and the way in
which data sharing database sharing
things like that happens across
platforms so that we can actually
identify the source of the decisions
that are getting made so that we can
hold the correct actors accountable
um
retention of and provision for access to
data is not I think uh
complicated to understand uh why that
would be helpful
um otherwise we are looking at these
individual cases and trying to come up
with conspiracy theories for what's
happening on a platform without actually
understanding uh things in the bigger
picture
um
okay uh
procedural requirements
I'm not going to spend too too long on
this
um
I think the the
kind of content moderation uh governance
and system that I'm much more interested
in is forward-looking and thinking about
risk assessments thinking about what are
the possible failure modes for yes
oh sure yeah
so the way I understood you saying it
was that uh you aren't like content
moderation we separate from other public
areas of the company because you don't
want them to influence how do you square
that with like Engineers
like how do you like weigh this idea of
like influencers just like even like
them having to work together yeah it's a
great question it's um because you're
right there is an inconsistency in what
I'm saying uh and so it's good to to
clarify and you know one hand I'm saying
we need to think of this much more as a
system and all of the product design
choices are influencing how we think
about content moderation on the other
hand I'm saying to the extent that there
are content moderation decisions made I
want them to be hyped off from people
that have uh contrary incentives so what
I mean by that this is a is that once
content moderation decisions are made
they should not be interfered with with
other parts of the company so for
example you I think it is relevant to
have like product growth teams in the
room describing describing the
incentives that they're building into
the platform and the values that the
platform is reflecting when you're
thinking about how do you think about
the rules but to the extent that their
incentives do not align with the
unbiased application of the rules once
those decisions have been made um as
sort of a way of ensuring that decisions
are both unbiased and also perceived be
unbiased is by ensuring that they can't
be interfered with after the fact by
people outside that
um a lot so and it's important because
I'm not saying let's abolish the appeal
system maybe some of what I've been
seeing might have sounded like that
which is not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is that we need to design it in a
way that is much more attentive to when
is it beneficial and when is it not
beneficial
um and and that is not the way that
these
systems are currently being designed
which is mostly
um I think performative
um
so thinking about this much more
interested in accepting that there is
going to be system failure and trying to
identify where this system's failures
are on an ongoing basis through auditing
and quality assurance measures and um
thinking about things much more uh at a
big picture level with continuous
Improvement rather than focusing on
individual mistakes happy to talk about
that more
um the the one thing that I you know
I wonder is that
um you know if I'd only done this
presentation three years ago no I don't
think it would have made any difference
at all but we are seeing a lot of uh
regulations and and things coming down
the pipe that are really based on uh
this this uh first sort of model and
talked about the EU Digital Services act
I've talked about Texas and Florida's
laws
um India is also uh establishing these
grievance of appellate committees where
you can appeal a system up to a
government-appointed appeals body
um those are only some you know
individual examples uh We've also seen
uh this model implemented in the form of
the meta oversight board which I'm also
happy to talk about uh much more I've
fought and uh
thought and written about it quite a bit
um but one of the reasons why I think
it's impact and its potential has been
is is limited is because it really is
based on this individualistic model of
like reviewing individual cases and at a
static point in time after a decision
has been made rather than thinking about
okay maybe this case like let's look at
a big group of pieces of cases and think
about what the system is doing to come
up with those outcomes and then on a
continual basis see how we can reform
that instead it's just like we'll put
this piece of contact content back up
and think about changing your hate
speech a lot of the time
um so as someone that was sort of
somewhat optimistic about the Supreme
Court when it first was announced in
2018 instead of being a Supreme Court is
it sort of more like the DMV instead of
revolutionizing online speeches are
going to sort of marginally maybe
improve it just a little bit um so I've
really had my expectations tempered on
that one because I think it reflects
this much more uh juridical kind of
model
um and I'm also happy to talk about this
I don't know how interesting it is for
audiences but fit for you but there are
a bunch of this is a really live legal
issue like really really live and um
there are a number of
cases on the Supreme Court stock at this
term and next term that are deciding how
the law should treat these systems
um Gonzalez and tumna are going to be
argued on the 21st and 22nd of February
um it's very exciting
um and the Supreme Court is going to be
thinking about how to
um should platforms be liable for the
ways in which they amplify uh content
and one of the things that I think is uh
informing this case having to talk about
it more is that
a lot of the way that the law and
lawyers and and potentially judges think
about content moderation and
amplification is like there's an
individual piece of content that the
platform is picking up and like
recommending to someone and saying hey
watch this video
um and so if you're thinking about it
like that it kind of makes sense that
yes maybe the platform should be liable
for like picking and saying you know
watch this terrorism with you but if you
step back and understand it much more as
a system that decision and Drawing the
Line uh between system design and
liability becomes a lot more complicated
um
I I won't go into the other uh
other cases except to say that the net
Choice cases there that I put up there
those are the ones are rising out of
Texas and Florida laws that we talked
about that impose all of these
procedural obligations uh on platforms
and so I I the the thing I want to
emphasize is like these could be you
know some of the most important internet
speech cases in a generation they really
could transform the way that this legal
landscape uh looks and the the platforms
operate in and the way that they need to
think about their system design and how
they think about content moderation
um and I worry that judges lawyers are
reaching for this old model of thinking
about how do we think about speech
regulation and uh importing it into a
new context so with that
um I'm happy to
chat here your thoughts
um
whatever happens next
[Applause]
so what happens next is up to you
don't want to kick us off
yep
um is there a vested ecosystem
um around creating
you know like the audit industry is in
with the big three companies and the SEC
watching it is there an ecosystem around
driving
this movement to the second wave
uh so I mean
it's interesting so
yes and no so in some ways
um
I blamed lawyers a lot in this picture
for in this presentation for how we've
ended up here but I also think platforms
are really responsible as well in a way
because if you are talking about
especially the large platforms when they
talk about content moderation
um focusing on individual decisions
means you stay away from the systems
that they're designing
um and so you know meta and and YouTube
you know they already have this
bureaucracy in place and so if you say
you know our regulation says you need to
construct an appeal system and provide
reasons meta and YouTube are like hey
here's one I provide I prepared earlier
um and all the other platforms are like
oh no
um and so I think there's an ecosystem
that is um
invested in sort of keeping Regulators
within that model
um but I think that we are seeing uh
like uh we we are also seeing
um
uh reactions to the to the costs of that
as well so Gonzalez which is at the
Supreme Court in uh in next month
um it had amicus briefs last month filed
which is when anyone can sort of say to
the court hey here's my perspective on
this case uh you should think about it
and it was like a flood of amicus briefs
from all across the industry from
business and from a lot of academics and
things like that concerned about uh this
model I think the question about
Auditors is really really interesting
actually because
um
we are seeing auditing requirements
being imposed in in legislation so for
example the Digital Services act in
Europe says that platforms have to have
a do a risk assessment and think about
having their systems audited uh to see
the the risks of their content
moderation systems in the world
um and have that independently audited
and
we don't have anyone that really like
knows how to do that we don't have uh
right well yeah how do you divorce uh
exactly I mean that's a whole other
question for sure but even just auditing
whether the systems are working
as they are intended to work whether we
think that what they're intended to do
is good or not
um like uh there is no content
moderation auditing industry currently
there absolutely will be in 10 years as
a result of this Digital Services act so
it's like a Full Employment Program for
for lawyers and or if you want a job go
to Europe and you can audit uh a Content
moderation systems and that could be
really really good as long as they don't
just become box ticking compliance
um
uh mechanisms as well so I think this
question about who has the expertise and
and what are they pushing for and what
are they thinking about is a really
really important one and I don't know
that we necessarily do have the right
ecosystem for pushing in a productive
Direction rather than letting it be
pushed in a direction that is that is
beneficial to the major players so yeah
foreign
how would you go about this process of
communicating to users uh like if we
were to remove some appeals process for
certain types of decisions some users
might be upset about this type of thing
how like are there techniques or ideas
that what a platform can employ to help
users like better understand this
decision and how do you react to like
the inevitable users that are going to
be upset about not being able to impale
some choices and then other companies
that might continue to allow This and
like having users like go to these
platforms that just allow more appeals
processes sorry could you repeat the
second off your question and then how do
you deal with like other platforms that
might just like allow there to be more
appeals processes as a means of like
gaining a competitive advantage over
some other platforms that are more like
restrictive about what can be appealed
or not
yeah so I mean I think it's it's a it's
a great point that in some sense
um
platforms offer
content moderation what do we want to
like appeal systems or like as a
consumer service
um like and and to the extent that they
do like I mean it's not purely because
they believe deep in their hearts in the
importance of getting speech decisions
right for the benefit of democracy it's
because they want their users to be
happy to the extent that they like want
to do it for the you know benefit of
their business they should my concern is
that it is being imposed in law in a
very unnuanced like every platform
regardless of their content moderation
model or their problems must apply give
these processes in every case
um and uh
like the way that these are written for
example at the moment would count spam
removals
um and uh having to provide a reason I'm
not convinced that the
um cost benefit trade-off is right in
that case now
you're right that in some cases so so
what I want is more of an X
anti-calculation of like are our errors
in this particular category of the kind
that will be benefited from having extra
review and having explanations to users
there will there be legitimacy dividend
dividends because for example you can
definitely imagine that yes many
spammers are going to be upset uh at not
getting an appeal and a reason for their
content being taken down but maybe the
legitimacy dividends aren't going to be
that high anyway even if you do give
them an appeal and say no we really
really want to take your content down
anyway and it's because it's spam
um and but there might be other uh other
categories where that where that's
different I want that decision made at
the level of system design rather than
after the fact
um but also and this makes lawyers and
many people uncomfortable
to say sometimes users can be upset
um like maybe that's okay and that like
we don't want to go too far in the
opposite direction of not paying
attention to user experience and things
like that but um but I I I'm not
convinced that this fixes that problem
anyway
um like there are just some people that
will appeal and appeal and appeal and
still be really angry at the end
um regardless of how much reason you get
you give them so
It's Tricky and I don't know what the
optimal like I'm I'm very humble about
saying I don't know what the optimal
level of appeal system and due process
is I'm not convinced that one blanket
Mandate of saying like this in every
case like the old legal system in every
case is going to be the optimal that
assumption I think is wrong
so as I'm listening to you I'm kind of
taking your argument to be that we need
to shift our metaphor right uh from one
about speech acts to one of that sort of
a system and so my brain starts going to
well how do you change metaphors right
what's influencing the metaphor we're
using today and it seems like this is a
pretty uphill battle because our
interaction with these systems
are as like individuals in this like
with individual speech acts the thing I
said got got taken down I am a senator
and I did this thing and now it's gone
versus when I think about when we
regulate stuff as systems or view them
as systems they're often more at a
distance like I think about like Finance
regulation it's like there's a big
aggregation of things that happen
there's kind of like the it happens in
volume and so I don't get personally
offended when one thing happens because
lots of things happen and then we can
audit sort of as a group so I'm feeling
kind of at a at a loss to think about
how I would even shift the metaphor even
if it's the correct metaphor how do I
get people to stop thinking of it in
terms of of individual speech acts like
how how do we actually
spread that gospel yeah it's it's a
great question and you know you watch
the Congressional hearings with the uh
the taxios
um which I'm sure you will do
um and um and you know exactly that it
said it as like you know my neighbor
posted blah and it got taken down your
platform is corrupt right it's like it's
really focused like it's that individual
experience that becomes really tangible
sometimes it's you know campaign videos
or or whatever and um it it is like I
really do think there is something about
the whole that speech has especially in
the American imagination actually
um that is very hard to dislodge that
metaphor because saying to
an American lawyer maybe sometimes we
can get speech decisions wrong is like
not a popular thing to say
um and and so so it is really really
hard there's this notion that speech is
special and when we're not going to
tolerate errors in a speech context that
we might or that we do every day in
traffic offenses and Social Security
Administration and like the legal system
is set up understanding that there are
errors in all of these other contexts
um that it that is very difficult to to
shift in in um
in in this context the only way to do it
is like through
um explanation and education and and
trying to like uh I mean a very open We
can brainstorm some metaphor ideas
um but but explaining how complicated
these systems are and and and the the
difficulty of um
of
uh of getting every decision right like
under uh trying to explain the scale and
the complexity and the technological
complexity you know people don't
understand why why didn't the
Christchurch video just get obliterated
from the internet uh within two minutes
after it was uh like surely everyone can
see that this is horrific but not
understanding that the technical uh the
technological challenge there the
problem is that the political
environment is so
um
it's so disincentivizes transparency at
the moment
um which I think is a real
problem because if a platform explains
oh we get this wrong a lot but here's
why
um all the people are going to hear is
oh we get this wrong a lot and that's
why I I talk about this as like the the
YouTube strategy um because like meta
for a while for a long time has tried to
be like has tried to explain itself and
try to explain its decisions and and had
like crowd tangle and things like that
so that are left whereas YouTube sort of
just sat in the corner and kept his head
down
um and by far a lot of the more of the
criticism was uh directed at the the
more transparent platforms it's the same
with Twitter where everything is much
more public
um and so I don't know how you fix that
I don't know how you fix politics
um but yeah uh I I agree it's a real
problem
oh okay uh
kind of going off of that I think if
we're thinking about the shift in
metaphor towards like systems thinking I
wanted to ask you about one of the
things on your earlier slides where
you're talking about institutional
design
um like what what is the institution
that we're designing in in your vision
of this like shift uh like is it
regulation from federal governments or
uh international law or is it also
including things like
um like Commons based or community-based
institutional design in the fashion of
like Eleanor Ostrom I guess
yeah
um so
when I was using institutional design
um there I meant uh
I guess both I meant the interaction
between our regulatory systems and our
private content moderation systems and
how do we design
that uh both of those institutions and
the interaction between them which I
think is very complicated
um so I and I think it is it's
complicated
um further by the heterogeneity in both
places so I think one of the one of the
problems is that um
we do think of platforms as like every
platform is meta and I think if you or
Facebook and if we talk to uh if what's
happening in these cases and in these
laws um is that you see judges and
lawyers and and approaching thinking
about platforms and institutions as that
institution
um and it's much more difficult to again
say you know all of these platforms some
use uh user-based content moderation
systems Community moderation uh and I
think like
um
talking about this with someone this
morning
um like one of the more valuable things
that we can do in the education uh
uh context is talk about that
heterogeneity
um so in the Amicus breeds for Gonzalez
um which I mentioned earlier one of the
most valuable briefs was from a bunch of
Reddit moderators
um who like uh the the moderators of our
equestrian
um where they talk about horses and
they're like whoa yo Justice Alito
Justice Thomas what we do is like really
different from what meta does
um we you know the the our form of
moderation is is really different and so
um I I'm entered in a very general sense
um and I think explaining why we need to
think about it uh in a general sense is
important
um how do you feel about like user and
anonymity sorry I can't talk but use
your anonym anonymity
um and how does it affect like these
cases that um like concern content and
like I don't know I'm guessing like
should you should you at all kind of
like
change anonymity at all because it's
such like a strong concept of social
media yeah I mean I'd love to turn that
question back on all of you because I'm
sure there's some people in this room
have some really rich thoughts about
that
um it is extremely popular
uh
legal reform idea to ban anonymity
um it comes up we do
cycles of this every few years the Brits
really want to get rid of it
um and uh and and
um and this idea that if people are
forced to identify with their name it'll
make them uh behave better
um and uh
everything will be solved
um and uh I mean my personal view is
it's not the case the research shows
that anonymity doesn't necessarily uh
you know Make spaces healthier we just
need to look at Facebook's real name
policy to see a lot of the problems with
a enforcing that and B that you know
Facebook is hardly
um Utopia
um and from
a sort of legal perspective and um
something that really concerns me about
that is that the the uh the consequences
that it would have on marginalized
minorities and activist groups and um
and especially if you're thinking
um if you're thinking globally
um in in uh jurisdictions where
being forced to identify with your uh
online Persona could have you know quite
extreme uh
costs for people in Iran turkey India
and many other countries that you know
don't mean to they're just ones I've
been thinking about recently so uh my
short answer is um it's again I think
one of the reasons one of the reasons
why we see these reforms and like get
rid of anonymity or add an appeal system
is really easy to write like it's like a
law that's like it's really you could
just write it down in two seconds on
paper and it just like it's it's it's
it's a simple thing that lawmakers like
um don't have to think too hard about so
it's it's it's simple and intuitive um
but I think that that it has significant
costs if we think about it so like in
those terms
okay so this question might be a little
mean to politicians but it like how
aware do you think they are about like
the actual impact of bills like this so
I'm thinking about like the the Texas
and Florida ones and then a ways back
the one that was like nominally to
protect the children but kind of like an
anti-encryption bill
um and so like with the Texas and
Florida ones now like we we just saw
Twitter like speed run but like not
having moderation to trust fire to
reinstating it yeah um do you think the
politicians who are putting forward
these bills like know what the impact is
going to be and are putting them out
with like other justifications to
fulfill some purpose or that they are
like honestly kind of ignorant to the
impact of the legislation that they're
trying to put out yeah I mean this is
one of the
uh
is one of the terrifying things I think
one of the things that makes Tech policy
so much harder is like
the average age in Congress is I don't
even know
um like the average Supreme Court is
even higher
um I uh you know the famous example of
this is in one of the very first
Congressional hearings where someone
asks Mark Zuckerberg how do you make
money and he's like Senator we run ads
like these people do not understand a
lot of a lot of them do not understand
these ecosystems
um and I think to their credit the later
hearings have been better due to some
staff work but I think you're absolutely
right like Texas and Florida
um Rhonda Santos and and Ken Paxton the
point of that law those laws was not uh
necessarily to really reform content
moderation and make it uh more
legitimate and procedurally beneficial
it was like in the middle of a campaign
uh election and it was railing against
the Liberals in Silicon Valley
um is is the impetus the motivation
behind those laws and so I think
politics here is is huge uh I think
that's much less the case with like for
example the European Union legislation
which I think is genuinely like they've
gone through a very long process of like
meaningfully trying to understand the
systems and and craft uh beneficial uh
uh legislation
um and then I guess it's interesting to
note how similar in some respects parts
of those bills look given that they're
um such different motivations
um
uh so I mean I think I think in answer
to your question uh no
um they don't necessarily understand it
and worse sometimes their motivation is
not to understand it um is to to for
other reasons which is the way that
um politics pans out but that's not
universally true I think there are
people who genuinely want to understand
this and generally interested in the
effects of it and I think we have seen
some of the worst bills and reform
proposals uh headed off for that reason
I think that we you know part of our
legal system has is you know you have we
have to have faith in the ability to
sort of push the Titanic towards better
policy
um despite you know uphill
uh that's a terrible I mix metaphors
there now the Titanic's going uphill but
um I think you get my drift yeah
um this might be a little bit salty okay
but um you talked a little bit about it
no actually you talked um a bit about
education when we were answering when
you're answering questions about how to
uh like we we need better education than
give people more nuances about how the
system works and how complicated they
are
um for the sculpture I like intern at
one of the companies that you talk to
their their moderation team during the
summer
um and it took me a very long time to
just even have a partial image of how
their moderation system work and how the
big picture kind of looked like I given
accessibility of those platforms to
different people of different background
and culture and Technology literacy and
um and even on top of this like
um there's analogy about uh moderator
being like judges and like our judicial
system but like even the moderators
aren't like
fully they don't get go through like a
full degree of like four-year education
of what content moderation is like and
how moderation system works how like how
practical do you think we can push the
nuances of content moderation system to
the general public because this reminds
me of like I had discussion classes
about how cookies work and then we see
them everywhere now people are generally
aware of how like they exist but even
that the nuances of like if you ask
General like if you ask my parents
um like when they go on website and then
they're asked about cookies how they
work they don't really understood right
so like how how do how much
um efficacy do you think there will be
on just pushing education and how
practical do you think it really will be
to solve this or are we just kind of
moving the burden of like dealing with
all these nuances up to like oh like
these are like now our user or consumers
problems sorry like yeah this could come
off us a little like me but like I just
no it's not mean at all I think it's
actually a really really rich question
um in a couple of ways uh because first
the question is like when I said we need
to inform the conversation better which
conversation do I mean there are many
conversations do I necessarily mean like
the general public or your parents or do
I mean the conversation in the halls of
Congress and I think those are both
important but they might look very
different in terms of what we want
people to understand like you know this
is something I think about a lot in the
context of like the meta oversight board
where you know the whole point of this
is like we're going to make content
moderation more legitimate and look like
it has better you know processes and and
and
um and give more transparency and
accountability and it's like I don't
know like
how What proportion of Facebook's users
know that this thing exists like that's
not the audience for that and and so the
audience for that kind of education and
the oversight board I'm probably like
one of like 100 people that has read
every decision that the oversight board
has ever issued down like it's it's it's
kind of there are there are different
kind of audiences um to to to
um to to different parts of this problem
um but you know I think
the other thing I think one of the
things that makes this so hard is this
is one of the most genuinely
interdisciplinary problems I think out
there uh in terms of you know you were
talking about like
um you know getting into these these
companies and moderators have different
skills and computer science have
different skills and then we want you
know uh lawyers and I think part of the
problem is coming up with common terms
and language and that's part of the
reason uh why I hope that these
conversations are valuable and trying to
understand ways
um to to talk about these things more
productively so again it's you know I
don't have like a a 30 minute video that
everyone can watch and finally
understand the complexities of content
moderation systems but I do think that
like starting to sort of talk more
openly about it
um and develop common words and tools
and and thinking about it rather than
relying on simple analogies
um
uh it you know is is a more productive
Way Forward
[Applause]